>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, WELL YOUR
RETIREMENT FEEL THE CRUNCH WHEN
YOU TRY TO BUY LUNCH?
IT IS TRUE IF YOU ARE ROLLING
LIKE A, YOU CAN A 4TH.
IT IS TRUE LUNCH IS SWEEPING THE
NATION AS WORKERS ARE RETURNING
TO THE OFFICE FACING SAME PRICE
POPULAR ITEMS.
THANK TO A SURGE IN PRICES NOT
SEEN IN 40 YEARS, YOU TAKE A
SECOND JOB FOR THAT TUNA
SANDWICH.
LAST MARCH THE AVERAGE PRICE IS
UP 18%.
SANDWICHES, 14%, SALADS 11%.
BERGER'S 8%.
MEANWHILE POPULAR CHAINS LIKE
SWEET GREEN AND POTBELLY HAVE
RAISED PRICES 6% SINCE START OF
THE YEAR AND TO SAVE MONEY
McDONALD'S REPLACE SPECIAL
SAUCE WITH SPECIAL REPORT SAUCE
COMMIT IS MADE FROM BRET BAIER'S
AFTERSHAVE.
I CAN RELATE TO THIS OBSERVED
PRICE HIKE MY SOUP WAS $17
YESTERDAY.
I'M NOT JOKING.
WHICH MAKES IT FAR TOO EXPENSIVE
TO DUMP MY ASSISTANT COLD.
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS TRUE.
MEANWHILE OTHER COMPANIES ARE
CAPITALIZING ON THE PRICE HIKES
AND REALLY UNUSUAL WAYS.
♪ ♪
>> HEY FAT ASS ARE YOU TIRED OF
LUNCHES THAT LEAVE YOU STUFFED
AND BLOATED?
>> NOT REALLY.
DID YOU JUST CALL ME FAT ASS?
>> THE PREMADE COLLECTIBLES FOR
SMALLER APPETITES.
>> I THINK SOMEBODY HAS BEEN
EATING THIS AND WHY ARE THERE
MATCHES?
>> LET'S NOT WORRY ABOUT THAT
NOW.
JUST $83 PER MEAL, LUNCH OR
BOWLS ARE ONE OF A DEAL.
>> YOU CAN HEAR HIM TOO?
>> HE WAS THE ONE WHO GAVE ME
COURAGE TO FINALLY BARTER MY
WIFE'S BOYFRIEND.
>> LUNCH-A BOLTS THEY ARE FOR
EVERYBODY.
>> Greg: TECHNICALLY DUE TO
INFLATION YOU WILL BE WORTHLESS.
>> WHAT?
>> YOU RUINED MY MOTHER'S
EVENING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU ARE STILL WATCHING?
>> PROBABLY.
>> Greg: GOOD FOR HER.
SHE WISHES I WERE HER SON.
>> PROBABLY.
IF YOU ARE LIKE THE WHITE ME
WITH MORE MONEY.
THAT IS PROBABLY TRUE.
>> Greg: I FIGURED YOU BEING
AND THE TECH INDUSTRY.
>> I HEAR MY TECH BUSINESS IS
BOOMING.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT FUNNY THING WE WILL COME
BACK TO THAT.
WE WENT THIS TOPIC,
PEANUT BUTTER AND JELLY TIME.
>> YOU ARE ASKING THE WRONG TIME
BECAUSE I GREW UP EATING
PEANUT BUTTER AND JELLY FOR TEN
YEARS AND THEN PARENTS HAD
ENOUGH TO GET LUNCH A BULL SO I
STAYED OUT OF THE INFLATABLE
MARKET.
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU PAID $17 FOR
FOOD.
DOES FOX PAY FOR THAT?
SPEED WHEN I GIVE MY ASSISTANT
$20.
>> YOU GAVE THEM CHANGE?
>> CAN YOU GIVE ME A FOOD CARD?
>> Greg: YES I CAN.
IT WILL BE A PUNCH CARD SO EVERY
TIME, YOU HAVE TO KISS ME.
THE TEMP KISS I GET TO PUNCH YOU
IN THE FACE.
>> DON'T GIVE ME INCENTIVE.
AND I HAVEN'T BEEN DRINKING YET,
KAT.
DO YOU EVEN EAT LUNCH?
HAVE PIEROGIES GONE UP IN PRICE?
>> BODY SHAMING AND THAT WAS A
LITTLE RACIST.
>> FILM XP WHEN I TRY TO PUT
THEM TOGETHER.
>> I ACTUALLY GO TO LUNCH.
>> Greg: ARE YOU BEATING MORE
BEANS?
>> AND MAKE THEM SEEM YOUNG.
BUT I HAVE -- I GUESS THIS
PROVES THAT OVER THE SUMMER AT
JOE BIDEN'S INFLATION WAS
TEMPORARY.
HE WAS KIND TO WRITE BUT THAT
INFLATION WAS TEMPORARY.
WE HAVE A BIGGER INFLATION.
AND IT WILL KEEP GETTING WORSE.
>> Greg: IT IS GOING TO GET
WORSE.
YOU KNOW, JULIE, THEY WERE
TELLING US A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO,
WE SHOULD EAT MORE BEANS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS A GOOD
IDEA FOR YOU.
>> THAT WAS A MARRIED PERSON IS
AT THAT FOR SURE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: SINGLE PEOPLE DON'T
EAT BEANS.
>> THAT IS ACTUALLY A GREAT
IDEA.
CANNED BEANS.
I GAVE UP MANY YEARS AGO, LONG
BEFORE NOW.
BUT I SAY CANNED BEANS IS THE
WAY TO GO.
I SUPPORT THAT 100%.
>> Greg: ARE THERE ANY
STATISTICS YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE, IN PARTICULAR CAN OF
BEANS?
>> I THINK IT IS GOOD, GO
SPANISH.
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T SPELL
LAGOON WITHOUT --
>> YOU AND ME, IS THAT A "YES"
OR "NO"?
IT IS BURNED INTO MY BRAIN.
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T SPELL
LAGOON WITHOUT YOU OR ME.
>> WHERE DID YOU LEARN THAT
STUPID --
>> Greg: IT CAME TO ME LAST
NIGHT.
>> SO I WOULD SAY AS FAR AS
GOING OUT TO EAT, MAJOR LUNCH AT
HOME AND -- THAT IS ANOTHER
SEGMENT.
THERE IS THAT ENOUGH FOR YOU?
>> Greg: I WILL TAKE IT.
BUT I RELY ON TRACE.
TRACE, THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS FORGET SOLUTIONS AND
JUST DEAL WITH IT.
THAT IS WHAT WE ALWAYS GET FROM
THE LIBERALS, THE LIBERAL SPIRIT
INFLATION, WE CAN'T SOLVE
INFLATION.
YOU WILL HAVE TO SUFFER BUT WE
WON'T SUFFER BECAUSE WE ARE RICH
LIBERALS.
DID YOU LIKE THAT?
BECAUSE THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF
THIS, PEOPLE ARE COMING BACK TO
THE OFFICE.
I WAS IN MANHATTAN A FEW MONTHS
AGO AND NO ONE WAS AT THIS PLACE
ON THE CORNER.
THERE WAS A LINE OUT THE DOOR.
PEOPLE ARE COMING BACK.
THE SOUP YOU NEED TO BUY IS 50%
MORE.
IT IS ALSO MORE THAN DRY
CLEANING.
YOU HAVE TO GET GAS TO GET IN
HERE APPEAR THE LUNCH IS $15
WHERE IT USED TO BE $9 THE CUP
OF COFFEE AND IF YOU ARE ON THE
EDGE, A DEMOCRAT, MODERATE
DEMOCRAT, INDEPENDENT YOU DON'T
LIKE IT.
YOU ARE GOING THIS WAY.
THAT IS WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS FREAKING OUT
BLAMING PUTIN, BLAMING EVERYBODY
BECAUSE NOW ARE BACK IN THE MIX
LIKE WHAT HAPPENED?
I DON'T CARE.
PUTIN MIGHT BE LAUGHING.
BIDEN IS SITTING IN A CHAIR
TAPPING ON HIS WATCH AND IF YOU
ARE IN THE MIDDLE, YOU ARE GOING
THIS WAY.
AND YOU BUY $6 FOR GAS.
>> Greg: HOW LONG BEFORE YOU
SEE PEOPLE IN THE STREETS
FIGHTING OVER ORGANIC CRUNCHY
SALAD FROM PROTEGE.
>> EVERYONE ON THERE ALWAYS
LOOKS SAD.
>> IS THAT HOW YOU PRONOUNCE IT?
>> Greg: THAT'S HOW I
PRONOUNCE IT.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE WEIRD,
TRACE.
BUT IT MIGHT BE GOOD OPPORTUNITY
COME INFLATION TO LEAD TO
DEFLATION IED LESS, LOSE WEIGHT.
STARVE, THAT IS WHAT